Forrest Gump was a big-time crowd-pleaser,
and a sequel would've definitely also earned
stacks of cash at the box office.
So what kept a potential part two from ever
hitting theaters?
Well, stop eating those shrimp and grab your
running shoes as we find out why Forrest Gump
2 never got made.
Once upon a time, Tom Hanks was best known
as a comedian.
But then the Oscar-winning double whammy of
Philadelphia and Forrest Gump turned him into
an esteemed actor and gave him serious Hollywood
clout.
Following those back-to-back Lead Actor wins,
Hanks could've easily made a Gump sequel,
but instead, he opted for Apollo 13.
So why didn't he revisit his iconic character?
In 1995, Hanks said that he didn't think Forrest
Gump 2 was a good idea.
For one thing, as he told Entertainment Weekly,
he was tired of all those catchphrases.
But more importantly, he was worried a sequel
would hurt the legacy of the original film.
As he put it,
"I have to confess I don't see this a franchise.
A sequel would ruin what we had done.
It would be like Jaws 2."
While Forrest Gump might seem like a distinctly
cinematic experience, the movie was actually
based on a novel by Winston Groom.
So when it came time to adapt the story for
the big screen, Paramount tapped Eric Roth
to write the screenplay.
Roth is an incredibly respected writer who
won an Academy Award for his Gump script and
went on to nab even more Oscar nominations
for the likes of The Curious Case of Benjamin
Button and A Star Is Born.
And as it turns out, in between writing all
these acclaimed screenplays, Roth was busy
hammering out a script for a Forrest Gump
sequel.
For a brief moment, it looked like we might
return to the world of Lieutenant Dan and
the Bubba Gump Shrimp Company.
But while Roth is a fantastic writer who's
produced some spectacular stories, his Forrest
Gump 2 script might not be his most... mainstream
work.
Forrest Gump is a movie that wants you to
cry.
And the saddest scene in the entire film is
probably when Jenny dies, leaving Forrest
absolutely wrecked.
Played by Robin Wright, Jenny has lived a
pretty rough life, and she eventually contracts
a mysterious virus that doctors can't cure.
It is implied that she succumbed to AIDS,
and that was going to play a big role in the
aborted sequel.
According to Eric Roth, Gump and his son now
lived in Florida, and everyone in his community
was going to freak out when they learned Forrest
Jr. contracted AIDS from his mom.
As Roth noted to Consequence of Sound,
"We had a funny sequence where they were [desegregating]
busing in Florida at the same time, so people
were angry about either the busing, or [their]
kids having to go to school with the kid who
had AIDS.
So there was a big conflict."
So according to Roth, Forrest Gump 2 was going
to use racism and the AIDS crisis together
for the sake of a comedy bit.
Those are two highly sensitive topics that
most moviegoers would probably agree aren't
the best fodder for humor.
In addition to the phenomenal acting and nostalgic
soundtrack, Forrest Gump is also praised for
its visual effects.
The folks at Industrial Light & Magic actually
won an Oscar for their incredible work.
Perhaps their most impressive accomplishment
was putting Tom Hanks into archival footage
alongside famous historical figures like Richard
Nixon and John F. Kennedy.
Eric Roth planned on having Forrest encounter
even more famous figures in the sequel, including
an iconic cameo that doesn't sound like a
great fit.
Evidently, Forrest was going to be very involved
in the saga of O.J. Simpson.
Somehow, he would be the one responsible for
tossing the bloody glove found at Simpson's
Brentwood home.
Stranger still, Forrest would somehow wind
up in the back of Simpson's white Bronco as
the football star leads the police on the
slowest car chase in history.
The O.J. Simpson trial was obviously a huge
news story in the '90s, but it would probably
feel bizarrely out of place in a Forrest Gump
sequel.
For all its happy moments, Forrest Gump is
ultimately a tragedy.
After all, it ends just moments after Forrest
gives a tearful goodbye at Jenny's grave.
As for the sequel, Eric Roth had no intention
of giving our chocolate-loving hero a happy
ending.
Speaking with Yahoo, Roth explained that Forrest
would have a new love interest: a Native American
woman he meets while riding a bus.
She was going to be a nursery school teacher,
and every day, Forrest would sit on a park
bench and share a lunch break with her.
But she wouldn't be teaching at any old nursery
school.
Instead, it would be located inside the federal
building in Oklahoma City where in 1995 Timothy
McVeigh set off a truck full of explosives.
Forrest's girlfriend was going to die in the
blast.
Worse still, it would happen while Forrest
was sitting on that bench, as the building
explodes right behind him, which sounds more
than a little tasteless.
So if Eric Roth had a script ready to go,
how come Forrest Gump 2 never got made?
It turns out that he turned in his final draft
on September 10, 2001.
The very next day, the world was turned upside
down.
The 9/11 terrorist attacks impacted the production
of quite a few films, and it stopped the Gump
sequel from even getting past the screenplay
phase.
After all, the movie was supposed to end with
Forrest's girlfriend dying in one of the most
devastating terrorist attacks in American
history.
And that just wasn't going to fly in the aftermath
of 9/11.
So on the day of the attacks, he met up with
Tom Hanks and director Robert Zemeckis to
commiserate.
"We looked at each other and said, 'This movie
has no meaning anymore.'
In that sense."
So it's probably for the best that Forrest
Gump 2 never happened.
From what we know of the screenplay, it doesn't
like it would've been anywhere near as beloved
as the original.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.